[Music]
Olia is in for her seven-month scan the
baby she carries is healthy
but it's not hers
so I've decided to do this for a second
time we are living through hard times no
income no jobs nothing this time it's
more about earning a living if I can why
not
even in Wartime Keith's state-of-the-art
biotech Clinic produces five babies a
day for a surrogacy fee of up to seventy
thousand dollars the women take home
around a third of that
when war broke out in February it seemed
the capital might be captured by the
Russian army within days Clinic director
Igor pechenoga LED A hurried evacuation
except that there really was no safer
place for 30 babies to stay and with
more being born every day the doctor
moved into the clinic with them where
he's remained full-time ever since was
there ever a moment when you feared for
the lives of the women and the babies in
your care here
always always
there wasn't the moment when I didn't
he shows us around cryogenic storage
tanks maintain healthy sperm and embryos
at minus 190 degrees for up to 10 years
in vitro fertilization takes place in
the lab before being transferred to the
surrogate
this is the result our boy our boy's
name is Nathan and Canadian citizen
Sonia and Manuel started the surrogacy
process just before the war broke out we
decided to move forward because we
thought that the water was not going to
last that long the war is nine months
old now and the parents have ventured
back into the war zone to take newborn
Nathan home to Canada they're full of
praise for the ukrainians who've made
their dream possible they are so brave
that I had the impression that I I said
to myself we have to be brave to come on
it's not you that is in war it's them so
come on you do it and be brave
evgenia survived the shelling of her
apartment building to become a second
time surrogate four months ago
genetically it is not my baby I carried
it for nine months and I talked to it
but its parents have been waiting for it
for a long time so you have to let it go
you let go in war bravery comes in many
forms and here the giving and receiving
of Life are among its Rewards Jonah Holt
Al Jazeera Keith